I call this video August and I'll tell
you why
August fascinates me I grew up in the
wine business where you did a lot of
business with Europe and the late 90s
early 2000s I was always confused by
August because August was the time that
I completely got in the zone because I
knew everybody was sleeping and what I
mean by that is everybody was on
vacation and you're up all my vendors
they were gone the whole month ghosts in
the u.s. a couple of weeks here a couple
of weeks there and you know it was
really interesting I just really used it
as my time to get ready for that fourth
quarter right people came back in
September and they were like just
rolling fast for that prime time I was
in retail for all you young hustlers out
there or only hustlers out there August
is the month this is the month where
guys even I'm taking plenty of time with
my family this is when people really
slow it down look for those out of
office replies cuz they're on the up
during August and if you're watching
this video right now and if you want it
as bad as I hear you want it and if this
is your year and if 2017 is gonna be
your year and if this is your moment and
if you're sick and tired and it's your
time then my friends you need to
understand that these 30 s or 30 or 31
these 31 I take 31 days hope that's
right in August
these 31 days in August is exactly when
you triple down when you 4 X 5 X down in
your hustle while everybody's at the
pool drinking rose' this is when you put
in the grinding hours and get ready for
your master plan August my friends is
always always the month that sets the
tone for your future for all the people
that are complaining or disappointed at
where they're at now gonna flip you a
little bit August is also the month for
all those people that are content grab
bags under the eyes hustled all year
crushing it it's a very strategic month
to kind of go into that rest period get
a little Sun play a little tennis play
in the pool with your friends your
girlfriend and your kids Asik August is
such an interesting month for me you can
play it one or two ways but it depends
on where your head's at
right now it'll be over before you blink
so don't play just don't play